gang quick announcement on the middle
class famous tour we are going to be
coming to a city near you for a live
stand-up show and playing ayg with the
audience we're going to be in san
francisco california los angeles
california la jolla california and we'll
also be in pittsburgh buffalo detroit
denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
then over there to roseman and that's
just to me we're going to be adding some
dates it's going to be a fantastic time
grab the squad come out and see us get
your tickets it's a good time welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy yeah yeah yeah
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day down here at antoni's
basement caught her upstairs rooting
through the mail uh-huh at the
neighbor's house okay my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman and it doesn't
matter how you get to laugh as long as
you get it and i got it this week and
payday's coming up give it up for kj
kevin james ryan that one was a little
undercooked if you ask me what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube as you know those numbers are
true cooking baby
and then petrie
is
on fire there's a sale everything must
go get in now
uh we're approaching our next goal which
is the yeah the ten thousand dollars i
got it man the ten thousand dollar
roulette's been uh on black that is of
course black always bet on black shout
out to wesley uh so check it out there's
you know over a hundred uh episodes of
ayg and hard feelings on there check it
out a lot of content do it yeah at ten
g's is
gonna be a real real bad timer right
there and if you're on the patreon you
know he ain't got it
[Music]
speaking of not gotten it how about a
nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire that was mean the magic
man makes us all look good my best pal
in the whole wide world and i love him
to death ladies and gentlemen doctor
toby mcmullen everybody oh what's up
dudes what's up t-bone good to see you
buddy dude hell yeah i just want to say
that bert episode's cooking and if
everyone hit me up i'm changing my
[ __ ] number
this kid's getting real high-class
real hoity-toity who's hitting you up it
was a bit
i didn't even call them folks i don't
know if i'm not calling them i don't
know who's calling them
i thought your name was tony until a
week ago
gang this is a family episode but we got
a little company in the building most of
you love them
[Applause]
he's family i don't know what to tell
you can't pick your family yeah pick
your friends but you can't pick your
family pick your friends pick your nose
but you can't pick your family that's it
he's got to go
kind of like liar
ladies and gentlemen it's cousiny and
finance everybody
love you guys glad to be here if you're
watching at home smoke them if you got
it
blur that out they're not paying for
that
dude it's only a matter of time till he
comes in here with his own brand
endorsements and he starts plugging him
with his own cigarettes
cough drops folks yup red bull gives you
wings
to fly back in time and delete that
[Laughter]
that's why you love them age new energy
drink red-faced
pick yourself up a red ball
is your sack red gives you lumps
red face gives you lumps
holy [ __ ] buddy good to see it's been a
while we haven't seen it since christmas
i know well you know christmas came
early this year because i'm back thank
you for having me
i love yous
and uh you guys say use and in delaware
we say yes
my family would do love yours
love yous lovesies i don't think that's
a specific delaware thing i think it is
i've only heard it in delaware shout out
to my newps my claymores he's only been
there in newark so it's not saying much
newark oh i'm sorry newark is jersey
newark is delaware
speaking of branding as well shout out
to blacklisted for the hat blacklist
from philadelphia feel like an
infomercial anybody
anybody else now
anybody else you owe money to that you
gotta give us
hey listen i know i ain't got the 2
grand but i'm going on a yg shout out to
yous painting in delaware
i'm also for sure going to bleep that
just because [ __ ] you what no oh
everybody check them out everybody
they're a great band
who would that's not a that's not a
philly's hat black blacklisted it's a
philly's hat but the b is for
blacklisted oh
they're no longer together i'm gonna
blur all your logos like a snoop dogg
video oh my god i can't wait till next
time i just wear shirts with so many
logos on him hey you come in like a
boxer yeah fig newton's on his glasses
i'm moving around so toby can't blur me
dressed like a big hamburger
sandwich
did you have you ever used a sandwich
board professionally i would have to
assume you had to have no never never
what about one of those signs were you
ever the guy out flipping
signs yeah like turbo tax or whatever
you've
for the salvation army once
where drinking the bell court order
yeah
i was a volunteer volunteer i wasn't
with salvation army i did it on my own
oh my god if you stand across the street
you can undercut them
they want a quarter i'll take a nickel
i'm with the salvation navy hello
wait what do you mean uh in high school
i used to volunteer a lot and so you
actually volunteer for the salvation
were you ringing the bell were you kids
sitting on your head i was ringing a
bell no kids are sitting on my lap stop
playing out your fantasies
can you sit on my lap yeah yeah i didn't
know you were the guy ringing the bell
or you were doing something different i
was ringing the bell outside of a super
g getting everyone to come super g super
giant it was a grocery store gotcha in
delaware yeah
so yeah it was fun went out to acme did
that as well i used to volunteer a ton
up until like
before college i was volunteering like
every other weekend it was awesome
really yeah i don't think i've ever
volunteered i want to get back into it
it's really fun it's been on my resume
my entire life my professional resume
yeah yeah
at microsoft excel
i'm proficient in powerpoint yeah yeah
no that i did that i did a bunch of
volunteer work like for waiting tables
and stuff yeah they never check on that
[ __ ] dude dude i went down south and i
helped uh tear out and patch up homes
that got hit by hurricanes after katrina
are you stealing copper oh you're doing
that there you make a lot of money that
way no no
yeah this one's totaled yeah yeah yeah
george is going to cover it anyway
stealing from a different house i
thought it was damaged
yeah dude it was awesome i loved it i
used to drive a van around the bronx
that doesn't sound safe
yeah we're just handing out life hand
out food to the homeless where would you
get the food i was part of a new york
cares you would meet at like a place
you'd load up the van with food then you
go around to these like drop off places
everyone lines up you hand out the food
and uh they called me the mustard man
because i was the guy that handed out
the mustard to him nice
specialist
gave you the big job
cigarette no it was fun ma'am
come back and they asked for more
oranges
wait what
yeah if you're you want like sweets when
you're on drugs coming down from drugs
you know
i wouldn't know it never come down
i'd like to keep it right up there folks
still love sweets yeah you and your
weight um
[Laughter]
you are cousin
he's also been trying to horn himself in
on the [ __ ] disney trip by the way
what's going on when we
when are we going to disney his pitch is
just this
yeah
huh am i right yeah i've always saw him
at the club the other night at the
mickey mouse years i was just gonna say
i already bought the ears god damn it
have you ever been uh i went twice in
school we had a florida trip you went if
you
i mean every room went but i almost
didn't go because i got i was one
detention away from getting kicked off
this is elementary school or high school
elementary school really what in
elementary school were getting pensions
in elementary school i was a bad kid in
elementary yeah
i didn't know they had the attention i
had to change my group of friends and it
was a blessing
because i changed my group of friends
they kept stuffing me in a locker still
friends with them to this day
shout out what about the old justin and
fred justin works for an industrial air
conditioning company the name of that no
we'll put his number up there
what uh what happened to the old crew
oh man
trouble really wrong side of the tracks
wrong side of the tracks buddy don't
want to get in who has wrong side of the
tracks friends in elementary school this
guy what could they have been doing that
was so bad what got you the detention uh
fighting acting out in class talking
back
um
having a mustache at eight
freaking out the faculty refusing
jacket
so you can't get it sorry you can't
smoking smoking in the faculty lounge
yeah hey how you doing i got my socials
mr whitney you got a light on you yeah
dude i i would ask so many questions
they limited me to two questions in
class you had to be what were you on
horrible you were on ridland what were
you on as a kid
start naming them i don't know
everything about roller skates yeah
that's a goldman line everything but
good behavior yeah [ __ ] pill bottles
yeah everything but the honor roll i
think no some of the bad kids were
trying to get me to give them my my
ritalin and they would give me weed and
you know seven you know typical seventh
grade stuff all right seven smoking you
know
so in seventh grade your school a public
school in delaware i didn't go to public
school you went to a private catholic
school okay you went to a catholic it
makes more sense they would do a trip
where you went down to disney world yeah
and it was like an it was incentivized
to make sure like you got good grades
you had to have a certain grade point
average who paid for it did the each
individual parents have to pay i think
it was paid by the sky i don't know i
think it's pretty good we took a
big old bus down wait you drove what oh
yeah wow that's not cool yeah that's
what do you think you were wrong drugs
you idiot yeah
you were [ __ ] you lit up
i know
a bunch of water balloons before it went
down
puking in a motel back i thought we were
auditioning for double dare yeah i have
some information that may change your
desire to go to disney world ever why
you can't smoke that's not true that's
not true that's not true that's not true
that's not your
no you can there's certain places you
can smoke for sure there's like one or
two in each park and they're very small
they're smoking it they're hiding behind
trees are you kidding me i'm smoking on
splash mountain splash meal yeah maybe
we wait until
after the you can go on the rise
[Laughter]
this is gonna be a quick trip to [ __ ]
magic kingdom you guys got any new
construction starting down there
hey we're gonna need some [ __ ] cranes
on the monorail maybe maybe
it's gonna be me it's gonna be me ian
and toby on your back in the lazy river
going down the white water ramp
there she blows
he ate two goofies
um
maybe we wait till after the casino
thing
how are we supposed to go and have a
good time we got that hanging over our
heads what the casino thing yeah well
the casino thing we can do in a night
i don't do the casino thing on the way
to florida are you kidding me i drive
into florida yeah do what the [ __ ] this
isn't father dirtbags
wherever the [ __ ] you went to school but
that's our lady of no how long was the
trip
seven days our lady of no money
i'm getting steamrolled over here saying
i owe you something
say thank you you were probably on some
[ __ ] no-fly list or something yeah oh
my god well dude one kid i bullied me
and i punched him in the back of the
head before the trip rabbit punches
i do well one of the construction
workers that was doing work at the house
told me if you get bullied you just run
up punch him in the back of the head
and so i did the construction work
well some vagrant yeah somebody your mom
took
just just because he fixed your mom's
bed yeah one of my uncles for the week
he told me
so i hit this kid and uh we ended up
becoming buddies on the trip
you know yeah threw him in an alligator
pond on the way i don't believe it do
you still talk to him say his name no no
no
no i only talked to three of the kids i
went to grade school with still friends
this day so you went seventh and eighth
grade
yeah and then in eighth grade i went
down as like a um
i guess you went twice in the same year
you went as a chaperone yeah like they
they had maybe like four or five eighth
graders and one with the seventh graders
and when they'd go and grow that was
like eighth grade i would like
you know he was wearing a helmet leader
you know
yeah making the decision i was a big
shot at epcot already been there oh man
the only kid on the trip sitting in a
car seat
he's wearing a diaper
i'm like still well in a league of their
own running up there
in the back of the head madonna wants to
beat you up
gina davis chasing you around the bus i
say
uh atlantic city casino you win
amazing time in florida you lose you got
florida to look forward to
yeah not a bad idea the only problem the
only problem with planning the the
disney church is we had it on the books
we had to move because we're going to
california next week yeah supposed to be
this week i think um
so that was the only thing we had to
change it but
it just takes way more time to plan that
you need to plan that and you know you
can't just [ __ ] get up and go we can
get up and go to [ __ ] ac tonight if
you want to that's right you want to
jump the gun wow let the money go wow
right that might entice them to join if
we go it's already in the can we'll let
you know how it goes oh i wouldn't be
able to poke it yeah
five weeks fully sheet right damn it
yeah yeah welcome to [ __ ] are you
garbage like goddamn patriots and if we
won i wouldn't be able to do it
desperately because i'm already thinking
about what i'm going to blow the money
on what i don't know taxes
i hope it's taxes
oh i got to call my tax guy
same tax guy yeah really everybody uses
it wow this guy's great
i'm writing off everything all right
do you talk to him or do you talk to the
assistant oh i talk to him really i talk
to him you do you're just a new bozo
yeah man
i even got past the secretary
i'm waiting in the
lobby
i'm waiting in the lobby with flowers
and candy like an [ __ ] uh gang this
is a family episode it sure is we have
business here at two four yeah and
that's when you sign up for the old
patreon there as pre mentioned here on
this particular broadcast you get a
question asked on the air whoa now as kj
says this is a memo from up top we do
have a bit of a backlog but this is the
best way to get on the show
that was not this week's memo or hit us
with a strong heater on [ __ ] twitter
yeah come come through with some goods
um
uh all right let's get into it a little
we got a couple of [ __ ] heaters this
one i don't know how this has never came
up this is for morgan first time long
time ten dollar homie have you or anyone
you know been an underage bartender what
yeah back in like there was shitty bars
where you could be like a [ __ ] 18 or
16 year old bartender i think that's
legal
i don't know you can in the state of
pennsylvania i knew kids when we were 16
for bartending we would go 16 down off
the boulevard no way yeah it was like an
old cop that's like a farmer ruling you
can drive at 13. i'm not saying it was
on the up and up ian i mean it was all
underage kids and like retired cops
what the hell is
god damn it couldn't get it out did you
ever ever have a pinata at an actual
opinion at a birthday party no i went to
one with a pinata yeah i've only been in
the tail on the donkey that was great
i'm remembering it now
really still remember the neighborhood
he was using a real livestock though
it's a real donkey this donkey's got to
be back by three he just keeps sticking
his finger in his ass oh i missed again
[Laughter]
uh you can serve booze underage in
almost any state uh the one who plays
the most fast and loose is maine which
across the board 17 let them fly oh i
like that wait mix it up huh so you got
to be a 17 year old checking people's
ids to see if they're 21. sure that's
crazy yeah you're not drinking
you're serving alcohol you're gonna be a
bartender not drink it's true why else
would you get the job as a bartender
it's 17. hey man i agree with you got a
good work ethic no you're trying to you
need the cash it's a cash job
walk with a stack of tips it is yeah
have you ever bartended
no have you worked in the service
industry yeah
waiting tables waiting tables or did you
wait tables oh new york delaware
graduation just naming states
wyoming
just states we've never been to yeah
we're not gonna go check
wisconsin where did you wait tables in
new york city oh lower east side a place
called cassanese no longer exists
directly across the street
from this kind of i would give people
free champagne and
say
and i would say i would use their last
name and say that it was mine and oh my
god do you have a cousin to try to get
like a relationship how would you find
out his name when he switched the card
yeah he would set the card to be like
all right john stevenson like you're
john stevenson yeah yeah
one time i did that and i was like oh my
god i think we're ladies like i'm from
south africa all right
good part of the bad part what are we
talking about
you know the disney world do you own any
diamond mines
oh yeah no then get the [ __ ] it was
directly across the street from the
school i taught at i could see you going
up the tables and being like if i talked
to the owner this bread's on a hill yeah
yeah yeah yeah i hated services like
supposed to do this but you guys seem
like nice guys you are probably robbing
that everything was making them to be
out to be a favor like oh trust me i got
you to try to get a tip listen we 86 the
shrimp but i think there's some back
there i'll take care i was banned from
getting [ __ ] drinks
here you go
you were banned from getting shift
drinks yeah at the end of shifts because
you made a fool of yourself no because i
was an alcoholic
well someone said two go hand in hand
two strangers walking tonight oh yeah
dude oh it was wild dude we used to walk
in and just do pill trades it was
[ __ ] great yeah it was a good time
back then oh yeah yeah that was
something
you're going up the tables you just mind
if i hang out for a little bit yeah my
shift's done can i wrap this up with you
taken
you pull it backwards hit like ac slater
good news
good news is they got some dessert
coming for us oh yeah
i'm sure that you
gave people free [ __ ] you weren't
allowed to give them free dessert when i
was younger and drinking but when i was
sober waiting tables i was
company man thrown through by the book
huh buy the book loved it one one of my
favorite jobs i ever had was i was a
server at this place at one thing called
eclipse
it's 500 north union street
[Laughter]
yeah it was awesome i never really
waited i bust
all growing no we're in and out yeah no
you weren't really in the biz dude we
did it in college you were busting
tables in college
i was the only bus boys
so much i got a head injury harry over
here
that was a great place
i would make more than the [ __ ] i
would be the only bus boy answered every
dirtbag
what they would get mad they'd like what
the [ __ ] because they'd be like it was
huge it was portofino on walnut street
remember that place wait they split tips
with the busboy yeah i get 10 of
everybody's [ __ ] thing really yeah i
think 10 right that's the going right i
think we do we bust our own tables
some restaurants
yeah we're talking about refined people
you were on pills and there's probably
no restaurants i'm just giving the
dinner mom's kitchen giving the
dishwasher right home he was this deaf
guy named randall he [ __ ] ruled
he would rap and it did not sound good
i was at a blaster radio
cousin ian
let's talk about athletic greens
athletic greens ag-1 ag-1 is the cool
kids college yeah as us guys who were on
it you know i started taking athletic
greens why's that because i was finding
this is me personally that in my
workouts i was getting tired when i
would bring athletic greens with me
i don't get as tired
i feel good it's got everything you need
it sustains me yes and i'm doing it an
empty stomach in the morning
helps the gut health gets me going
through the whole day 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
super foods probiotics
you're an idiot uh best thing about it's
like a multi it's like a power
multivitamin it's got everything you
need in it that's what it is right there
huh it's lifestyle's in the pudding baby
it's lifestyle friendly whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy-free or
gluten-free it contains less than one
gram of sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals
or artificial anything while still
tasting good delicious it supports
better sleep quality recovery mental
clarity alertness uh it's got everything
you need what are we doing here just get
involved with ag-1 if you're working out
i'm telling you give it a shot it's
fantastic right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the cold and flu
season just one scoop and a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills or supplements
to to look after your health to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com garbage again that is
athleticgreens.com garbage take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
now back to the show back to the show
sometimes oh man yeah the bus boy
usually gets ten percent of everybody's
take and the runner too right
that's what i started out as i started
out as a runner and then worked my way
up to a server in like a week whoa
i mean dude it's like you got to the top
of [ __ ] nasa buddy let me tell you it
was you and def randy
it wasn't the strongest competition and
i think we're gonna go with randy on
this one
you get brunch randy's handling the
[ __ ] weeds all right
me and my [ __ ] crew at the restaurant
dude one of the one of the dishwashers
one time called me tortuga
because i was very slow
i remember one time i was busting tables
at uh this place called giuseppe's and
uh i was like seventh eighth grade maybe
and i spilled water all over the ground
like the cup overflowed in the bus pan
or whatever and i had so i didn't have
anywhere to put it so i went and got
like a rep before i could go get a rag
and come back
this [ __ ] heavy this heavyset
waitress who was the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ate
[ __ ] in the middle of the dining room
with a full tray of food for like table
18
foley in a wig
you're not wrong you are not wrong my
friend with the pants too high up uh-huh
the ass really sticking yeah the flat
ass and like the big the fat but flat
out the little server thing going all
the way around we're in the same pants
for like two weeks yeah they're all like
dumb in there there's flower stains on
them and [ __ ] oh yeah
dude you felt it in the back would you
hit the ground dude the [ __ ]
the neighborhood rattled and i knew
right away i heard it i went oh that's
me that's a guy give me all of them oh
my god that's awesome
13.
i'm gonna take my staff meal and get the
[ __ ] out of here my two free slices man
the old the the older the older female
server that's been there too long is
really something else oh did a really
good job in waiting on that but the girl
that was crazy but she was cool when you
hung out yeah waiting waiting really did
it very well yeah fantastic holds up
yeah watch i just watched like two weeks
yeah yeah yep dude you know what holds
up as well
kingpin oh yeah one of the all-time
phenomenal yeah good guys watch that i
think i watch it on a plane something
you know what doesn't hold up weekend at
bernie's i mean did you expect it to it
never held to begin with
i mean at seven i thought it was the
best movie in the world when that when
he's pulling the horse and carriage
that's a good [ __ ] you know what
doesn't translate he-man believe it or
not really
you know what remember they don't
they're all on tubie gi joe he-man
transformers generation one
oh brutal
i don't even know what that is
every day they got all the columbos
sounds like something they're plugging
you up to
i mean you got seven cc's of toby for
this lord
[Laughter]
that's not is we got him on the tubey
i don't even think it's kind of big his
insurance covers it either
can you do two two b's not i'd kill him
i feel like jaws taking barrels
i've never seen a guy take three two
beats before
i'm still running around the hallway he
can't get me under control
i'm dragging those barrels
yellow we're gonna need a bigger tubing
we're having a good time folks
having a good time
cousin ian stopped by
he had presents for us he said i did
whatever
it's what every dirtbag i believe was
the same uh wool you pulled over our
eyes at christmas yeah
you had just forgotten our presence
[Laughter]
you're just here
no i got you guys lighter covers
we can't wait to throw that out
yeah just put it in that white bin over
there on your way up
you never lose a lighter when you got a
lighter cup i'm never going to use a
lighter really neat we smoke a lot you
guys ask for light you also look like a
gypsy with that thing dude yeah there's
like turquoise and metal first of all
it's about three and a half pounds it's
you'll never you'll know where it is
it's a paperweight you can use it to
punch someone it's fantastic i got you
one more silver on you than a navajo
priestess too by the way
hey sam elliott take it easy will you
easy uh i
yeah love it i got you one with a little
feather and turquoise back to the res
and uh i got fully one that's a sexy
grandma
i can't wait to give it to you
but seriously you didn't get this for us
because it's not here well it's at my
apartment if you want to come home tv
and bombs a lot
keep lose his hair
cheevy and bombs a lot
i gotta talk to the i gotta talk to the
chief
i can see you doing that too doing a dna
test to find out if you have any native
american in you so you get your hands on
a casino
i just do it for the cheap cigarettes on
the reds i'll bartend yeah that'd be
amazing can i shift drink now and what's
the pill situation around here are we
doing swapsies today
doing swapsies on some leads and
pre-shift
talk about a dirt bag can you imagine
amazing i never worked in a restaurant
where everybody wasn't taking drugs and
it wasn't just
everyone's [ __ ] each other everyone's
stopped drugs there was always the hot
couple there was always the cool guy
where did you fall in that
the hot couple the cool guy and
the guy sweating in the corner
the guy eating someone else's chicken
fingers chief sweats too much
i would get real comfortable places real
fast
and just that's when the [ __ ] eating
off people's plates starts
when you don't give a [ __ ] like because
you know a lot of times the female
servers are all tense they're all a
little bit younger they're smoke shows
when you get comfortable with them
enough to [ __ ] eat some 50-year-old
guy's burger right in front of them
that's when you know you've crossed the
line time to start getting the
applications out there have you where
where would you eat the food i would put
it in my pocket and then eat it in the
bathroom and then
go down to the walk-in and drink it full
of meatballs
i got a pocket full of
where would you eat it
uh i would eat it um on stage
yes i do frequently no you've been i i
just got to say it has been awesome
working the cellar together it's really
[ __ ] neat foley's been crushing the
stage and um
had to bring in an architect i heard
we need some
support
to find to sign an agreement every time
i get out there
um this is how crazy i am i was mad he
didn't compliment me i didn't pick up on
the joke
he's like folly's been crushing i'm like
what the [ __ ]
i've had some good sets
that's some great ones been very good
times awesome it's been an honor to
bring you guys on stage it's very nice
anywho i would eat it when i dropped it
off
back to the food
stop talking about our occupation back
to my passion project
[Laughter]
eating leftover food from streams i
would eat it as you cleared off the
plate
real quick oh in the back yeah yeah roof
it down yeah
would you ever do it maybe a sweet low
pack in there put it into go box so you
got a whole buffet sitting waiting i've
done that put it into go box and put it
up there there's a lot of eyes
everywhere some restaurants nobody cared
you got to do it was something you
really did dude when i was in the back
and uh pulling the meats for um that's
how you call it i immediately regretted
that when i said it and i was back with
the other bus boys
hey you got to get the good shifts you
know no we would uh we would pack it and
hand it off to each other like a drug
deal like you'd walk past someone and
hand them a thing of meat then you just
the other guy go eat it and then you do
that you do that with like the cheeses
or the meats and the bread i was i never
i never like properly stole anything
like out of like i wouldn't like put
like a steak in my thing and bring it
home no no i'm not saying that i'm
saying like you definitely did stuff
like that i mean a couple times
no i never did that thanksgiving walking
with a case of lettuce i did one time
you got everything half off
this was my iceberg
check the cameras i came in with it i
mean you really got a speed when you got
a [ __ ] plastic bag full of calamari
that's the kind of yeah i got to get
home this is about eight minutes left
turns around the corner
oh man where's that case of snow crab
legs
they're all sticking out of your pocket
kidnapping lobsters on a lobster tank
you see anybody else
tape up their mouths and put them in the
trunk
well he's kidnapped we got to kill him
now
holy [ __ ] that's great all right all
right this one's from sharon new patreon
member first question ever vacuum your
bed sheets
yeah that's great yeah you got to yeah
when you got a cat
yeah i vacuumed my bed sheets i vacuumed
the couch question are you vacuuming
with the actual vacuum yeah or do you
have an attachment no i'll put that i'll
i'll put that on there you're putting
the whole vacuum on a bed i'll put the
vacuum on the couch too and [ __ ]
that's 100
you got to have an attachment dude
you have attachments and you don't use
them no because what do you mean it's
bigger and easier you just do a couple
passes on the sheet and you're at it
bigger and easier all over the all over
here it's lower than the hoverboard you
look like a full no it's not yes sid
it's all it's in my apartment it's all
the same that's not the case it looks
like you're trying to de-ice a silverado
the way you're reaching across the bed
are you kidding me
this is just pure laziness
to not hook up the attachments that's
yeah dude you got it i think it works
better because the attachment doesn't
have the wheel inside that sucks
everything up really good or reasonable
attachments are in there
for that reason i understand the people
at dyson have done the work yeah dyson
you think you know better than dyson
i don't think i know better than dyson
but i don't have a dyson when i get a
dyson enrica
hoover
dirt devil yeah what do you got black
and decker what are you working with
maybe it's a hoover yeah larry hoover
whip and work dude
you're an insane person okay to
stand
use the attachment treat yourself okay
all right that's bananas
try it out
i'll try it out i thought it was the
best way to do it
have you ever done it to a coat
vacuumed a coat
we also have this thing that goes
like that it has like felt on the bottom
that's for the for the cat yes you use
that one of those that's great on the
couch not plugged in how often do you
change litter
say it on three one two three once
what's it supposed to be
no i do it like every other day
okay yeah how are you you're not in
every other day no no she keeps that
really i'm the litter guy there no yeah
i don't handle any of that stuff i'm
getting an automatic litter guy i feed
her every once in once in the morning
she's really getting up
[Laughter]
when there's enough left over
[Music]
spraying over the water bottle
i'll come home whenever i want i eat all
the food myself
no
he's on the couch as a laser boy
see i pay attention to you
oh man i get the butterfly
no i'll if she doesn't feel like getting
up i'll get up and feed the kitty
but i'm not going man
that wasn't that litter was in our room
for like a week when when her sister was
staying in the room in the room dude i
was like get the [ __ ] out of here you
gotta invest in an automatic litter
cleaner i know she's pushing for it
the fans out there venmo at ian fi dance
why i'll film it it'll be fun
so you don't have one i'm gonna get one
if somebody pays for it it's just two
with two cat no i'll pay for it with two
cats it's a lot
i mean the thing gets full you know
every other day
is a stretch dog shit's really bad at
night dog shit's really bad but nothing
on this planet compares the [ __ ] cat
[ __ ]
it is vile well you gotta get the the um
um the litter that the deodorizer we got
all that [ __ ] you should wear
deodorizing yeah what do you think well
then why does this smell so bad what are
you feeding that guy chili
it's a
three alarm fire chili cookoff every
weekend mostly just hot sauce
he loves franks
a lot of spaghetti chicken wings
they're so cute when they lick out of
the water bowl oh man cats are the best
hats stinks
i'm a dog man shout out to hans head of
security
we say she's getting a little water she
had no water
so we say he brought it up no we didn't
i go and i go look at this little guy
yeah you're just a little guy
good morning hans nice to see you get to
work yeah that's how you talk to a
[ __ ] journey how much money have you
made today
i'm working for your kippy
you gotta get a cat
[ __ ] nuts no they're the best they're
the best
dude they're so cute
yes and the way they play with each
other you can't beat it we're cutting
this what i'm kidding
you gotta ah dude so if you get a cat
with your dog your heart will be i would
love it i'd get another dog before i get
a cat are you gonna get another dog
you're gonna do two dogs can't have
hanzi in there by himself you don't want
to be an only child you have to be a
school shooter yeah
[Laughter]
oh man
you got only kid vibes yeah
you can't tell i'm an only child
after yeah after knowing you for of
course you can yeah yeah you're straight
crazy dude yeah i know 100
it had been cool to have like a brother
or sister be like these people are crazy
they would have hated you you know
brother sister yeah think about that
look at that you wouldn't he wouldn't
be i'd be a different person sure yeah
so it's good i i was an only child
either maybe more well-adjusted or or
even worse
i think it depends whether you were the
younger you would have done well as the
older as the older yeah yeah
yeah as a younger cause we're all
younger we're bad news really i'm a good
kid what are you talking about a lot of
comedians are the youngest yeah are they
you have to look you're looking for the
attention i thought a lot of communions
are middles
no i think it's younger oh that's pretty
good this guy with his subtle [ __ ] uh
industry humor today sneaking it in
[ __ ] danny deep cuts over here
hey road dog reggie relax
dude that's this guy's talking
his leg's just lighter i know
you're gonna love your lighter cover all
right i i bet 400 bucks i never see this
phone never see it it took you six
months to bring the [ __ ] bathroom key
back i know
also we haven't gotten our christmas
gift and it's march what'd i get you i
don't know you said it oh it's like i
just got delivered
whatever you lied about i'm trying to
help you guys out i decided you don't
need the candies so what'd you do with
the candy i ate them even to my kid
he loves it i would love to know how how
many christmas presents each year you
buy for somebody else and just end up
keeping for free i get
little candies and i wrap them and give
them little shops in my neighborhood
that hook me up throughout the year i
bring him to different clubs and you
know give him like a little candy he's a
nice guy no he's low ready he's always
looking for a d looking for an edge
you're talking about he's always trying
to game you're not friends with with
your little shopkeepers in your
neighborhood they give me discounts
underneath i am now it's a dog the dog
in the coffee shop is like yes you bring
them in yeah that's in carriage dude
thank you thank you there's a latte man
they give you little discounts you talk
to them
friends with everything i love being
friendly and then at the end of the year
here i know you're
you know yemenis but merry christmas i
don't think that's a thing here's a fun
size snickers
thanks for all the free coffee this year
no it's nice here's a nickel stop i walk
in here's a half eating twix they give
me what i want ahead of everyone else
and then you know it's nice i like it
give it to my pharmacist you know
cool shout out feedback vna pharmacy
no prescriptions needed
just a wink and a handshake if you catch
my drift yeah he'd be surprised with a
pack of showers also sour skittles can
get you
all right this one's from bernie sanders
nice
um
is it garbage to strip the bed before
you leave a hotel
i don't even get that i think that would
be nice in class yeah
do i strip it and put it all like in the
middle i guess if there's like a lot of
i throw covered in [ __ ] yeah i throw the
towels in the in the corner i i try to
put my
try to clean up nice
we were just talking about this what do
you tip interesting let's do like you
stay a night or you know
you know what are you talking i admit
i've been bad with it he's he's been bad
on the road i'm bad with it yeah on vaca
when on vacation i give we make a point
i give five bucks a day
really that's good yeah what do you
think
uh i don't believe you really no why
you're notoriously cheap what do you
mean i'm notoriously giving snickers out
to the other
guy give candy to people
you've been trying to sell me a bike for
like three weeks i got you guys gifts i
was gonna give it to you
i'm trying to sell it to you
i was gonna give it to you for 750
dollars hey that's a steal you're
robbing it
for it
technically you're robbing me yeah and
it was coming with a helmet what are you
talking about
and a lifetime of guilt i'm gonna hold
over your head yeah how's the bike tobes
swear on your mother's life
swear in my mother's eyes five bucks a
day
say it say the whole sentence
swear on my mother's life i give five
bucks a day when i stay at a hotel i
have a
and he also rolls with the tell who's a
notoriously good temper yes hey you only
got to take care of the road take care
of the people yes good morning
yes and i tip out how much you tip out
comedy staff at the club we do pretty
well on the staff
always what do you do
yeah uh what do we do you want to know
what we do going rate for the waitress
40 to 50. it's now 50 something for the
weekend we're doing one night we do one
night
yeah so we hit them fifty we're gun
slingers in and out
we hit him 50 we hit the waitress we're
a waiter 50 for the night and then if
the bar or if the security guard is
helping with pictures at the meet and
greet he gets a double gets a dub yeah i
see him get something at the bar
i only get waters
so i'll give you know like if i'm just
getting waters and i'm literally walking
abroad i'll still give like a 20. sure
if it's a headline weekend i'm giving uh
50 a night or a hundred sure have them
split it up yeah yeah yeah always gotta
take care of you you always gotta take
care of yourself as always because
they're the ones it's also too like
there's a little behind the curtains but
like the staff she has the she or he
the server has their own section already
outside so it's not like they're just
chilling in the green room just waiting
for you it's like they're leaving the
people that are actually
paying their you know paying them that
night you always always got it you
always gotta take care of them um but
once we started bringing tommy on the
road to open up tommy's seat let me see
he uh now there's four of us in the
green room oh tommy no tips
i'm learning
so tommy tommy orders three meals
yeah tommy's tommy take homes
alligator arms yeah topping takeouts um
tommy foley would have paid for this
which means hippie would have paid for
this
yeah tommy usually gets a hot meal yeah
so
this is only of the day
so it depends on who but at least one or
two is ordering food probably yeah i
might get something to nosh on and then
i'll get a couple of beers he might get
a couple of beers but that's it's real
low you know low stakes yeah but you
gotta take care of them you got to
always yeah so five bucks a day huh
that's good i'll do five if i don't
i'll i refuse to leave once just because
in my head it feels dismissive so if i
have like three ones or a ten i'll just
leave the 10. yeah just to be like
totally and i i try to leave the room
like nice oh i'll definitely if i have
trash i consolidate all the trash yeah i
never leave like or whatever you know
yeah that's why the sheets i mean i it
depends what you did to it yeah if
you're trying to hide something to make
it not look like you don't want how do
you sleep do you do you untuck do you uh
because sometimes i'm rolling around and
i got that
done pillows are everywhere i mean
untucked like how it's tucked underneath
yeah oh yeah get rid of all that [ __ ]
yeah yeah 100
i also i think last no in utah i did
late check out and i was late on the
late checkout and the one was like
waiting so i gave her 20. i felt that's
good got to take care of them yeah
when you take care of other people
you get taken care of later it's good to
put out karmatic good into the universe
i'm i'm i'm i'm big on that now that i
have where's my [ __ ] christmas
present
buddy save it for next christmas two and
one shot yeah you'll get two you'll get
two fun bite-sized snickers next year
think about them again that's a whole
candy bar
hold out your hand
i think it's the bag hey it's [ __ ]
doing hold your hand down
uh i i got a quick one that came across
my my board came across
t-bone yeah it's for my boy willie
griswold okay real name wow really he's
french
[Laughter]
i'm back
he reached out to me and said hey i have
an are you garbage questions yeah yeah
okay on the show he works on the bob and
tom show out there b and t nice uh
have you ever have you or anyone in your
family ever gotten their hair cut at the
mall oh yeah
i believe we might have mentioned this
because i said that there was this one
place
uh at the plymouth meeting mall back in
the day that was like hot like all my
cousins went there everybody went there
to get it done it was like a vidal
sassoon kind of vibe ooh a barber shop
on the other hand in a mall
is superior trash yeah anyone with the
thing out front spinning around yeah
yeah no real out of the way it's always
down in the corner like next to the boss
in the radio shack or something oh yeah
it's always tucked away in that entrance
no one goes to that's a bit i'm i don't
like doing anything that's inside
something that you know what i mean like
if in the real world they're stand alone
yeah that i i like i can't go to a
[ __ ]
restaurant in a mall yeah no i can't go
to a starbucks in a [ __ ] hit that
cheesecake fact
you're kidding me you're not going to
the starbucks at a target oh all the
[ __ ] time getting some [ __ ] coffee
it's like being like i'm not going to do
that
no if i'm at a target yes then i'll go
but i'm not going to get my hair cut at
the mall just i'm not going to the mall
only for a haircut so i think i think i
think i can interpret this so let's say
kevin worked uh
had a job in the suburbs and he was on
his way to work every day he wouldn't go
to the starbucks at target to get his
morning coffee he would go to the
stand-alone store or a donkey's i would
have to choose but what if it's on the
way no that's the inconvenience of that
weird yeah the inconvenience of entering
a target parking lot target parking
through
there's lights in those parking lots
then you got a 20 yard [ __ ] you got a
30 yard walk that's a smart play because
the other one with the drive through
everybody's take a drive through so you
go to the target for the fastest they're
all they're always packed they're always
packed that's insane that's why you
become friends with them and they hook
it up
that's why you give him a candy corn
first for a small bag of goldfish once a
year yeah you two can get free coffee
hey hold on you know who's calling right
now
a discount it's yours
can't eat that banana right now never
i've never had a banana in my life
no i swear to god yeah what yeah
uh uh my wife was eating one last night
and she went in to kiss me and like i
even like why can't i take a bite and
try it i don't you never even had banana
runts
that's not a banana but yeah i mean i've
had banana flavors you've never had
something completely different
artificial banana flavor is
a-okay you gotta try a bike i think i
think that i think yes you you don't
have to do it right now i don't want to
force you but i think that's something
you have to do
how about this i'll do it when you lose
20 pounds why when i lose 20 pounds
you'll eat a banana so you're never
going to eat a banana yes
[Laughter]
i'll agree to those terms
shake yes [ __ ] safest bet that's ever
been made i know buddy i'm never
touching a banana
hey i think i give a [ __ ] of this bold
prick eats a banana and if you die it
doesn't count
low potassium kippy
yeah i don't give a really give a [ __ ]
wow never had a banana why it just never
came up or you having a car
yeah i have really weird stuff with food
odd like what else
i didn't start
we just did this in an episode was this
a was that a public episode we did that
i can't remember either can i um
i don't think it was uh
i don't know i real like i didn't start
eating red meat until way later in life
yeah like
mid-20s probably
did you guys know any kids who had to
have the the plate with the dividers so
their food wouldn't touch yeah i didn't
need it but i didn't mind it
i'm always mashing food together wait
hold on now that i'm an adult i'll have
i'll do it hold on how do you get your
steak cooked uh typically medium but if
we go out as a group and we order as a
group it'll be medium uh rare he's a man
about that stuff
but that's only that's only new that's
like all i'm ready for me to order a
steak at a restaurant it's crazy i'm
steak rare pittsburgh blue black and
blue charred cold red in the middle
alright mcconaughey
hey true detective relax
you're twirling a beer candy i want it
to still be able to lie to me
[Laughter]
this might bring the vibe down a little
bit great let's do it
yeah hey let's shift the gears up
yeah someone pulled the e-brake yeah big
man hit it hey hit this section
the thing with the food here we go the
separating of the food the first time i
when i witnessed that like experience
true poverty
was this this really really poor family
that lived in my house
baby sometimes i'm too quick for myself
that kid don't need a banana
yeah [ __ ] your potassium all right
i gotta pause the camera so i can wipe
fully's brains off
pink mist
he just lost 20 pounds
[Laughter]
my wife's trying to climb out the back
of the studio
good piece of business damn
anyway next question's foley's [ __ ]
yeah what were you saying big guys yeah
hold on let's get it back to sad i was
saying that the bottom of my
neighborhood was like a bunch of like
older shittier houses that when we lived
in wilkes-barre and we used to pick this
kid up he went to he went to my school
but i think that was the only time he
ate that was that day at lunch and it
was it was like ocd he ate one thing
here one thing there one thing there one
thing there and if they ever touched he
like like freaked out in the lunchroom
or if anybody ever like went to touch
his food he would freak out could you
relate
i was the one trying to think
they're not going to eat that cornbread
are you
it touched the bees but we did it
in the trash
what do you know you can't eat it
we're a hungry hungry hippo at the
cafeteria
we did have a kid in my third grade
class that if you touched any of his
food he wouldn't eat it and that was i
did that almost everywhere i did my best
work yeah
for snack time when he pulled out a
cupcake what's that oh that's all you
had to do was just put your i mean what
special needs school did you go to with
these freaks what are you talking about
like they weren't freaks there's another
guy who wore a face mask yeah you must
have been their god king jesus christ a
face man
i just pictured like freddie like a
jason mask or something
yeah that kid joel i remember like
realizing like oh [ __ ]
this kid's [ __ ] hem though why don't
you name more give away more of his
identity
i don't think he's still with us
so he had the nutrients to survive this
long
to bear those cold winters and we'll
expect three years of me
kid never got a piece of protein
must hate a burrito
yeah
any other um
you know tragically devastating stories
you want to bring up from my childhood
yeah did any kids have leukemia growing
up or yeah my best friend died when i
was in kindergarten really yeah
from what
[Laughter]
we were in kindergarten and i started
going to his house
and i went to his house every day was
like come out and play around play and
every day his mom told me no when this
went on for like six months and then
finally she called my mom and got a hint
i was i didn't i didn't know what was
going on yeah she called my mom an
ambulance out front every day
what the hell's he doing
the generator for his dialysis
we need one more for kickball what's
this what's this kid's deal
she called my mom and said tell him not
to tell him to stop doing that i guess
he was getting worse and worse i didn't
know he was sick yeah it was the cancer
and then the fat one keeps eating our
bushes can you keep him off the property
this kid's a billy goat
[Laughter]
he keeps rummaging through our trash
ah no but then we moved and then one day
i was like mom when can we go up and see
and she was like oh you remember that
funeral he went to a couple weeks ago
that was his he passed away you went to
the funeral and didn't remember
i busy at the buffet yeah my parents
went where do finger foods
[Laughter]
little fat kid no friends what are you
gonna do
i have to bleep that are you telling us
your autobiography
bleep that too
all right
this one's from luke everybody shoot
this much he can't miss
uh ever use a t-shirt as a pillowcase
sure yes i did it not too long ago yeah
big fan of that big thing especially if
it's a soft t-shirt oh man
it's like it's just perfect for it plus
you can put them on a bunch of pillows
but like you got friends
a couple of body pillows hey steve
i'm having an orgy tonight watch a movie
together
yeah
catch trash
all right have you ever
oh i don't like this have you ever taken
clothes in a towel and used that as a
pillow
yeah definitely been hemmed up using
clothes as uh when you know when you're
jammed up you're not towels i've used
towels as blankets before oh yeah like
big beach towels for extended periods of
time especially when you're in dude in
the middle of the night especially if
you're drunk and you're hanging you're
like sleeping somewhere and you're like
at your boy's house and the couch or the
floor or something and you'll wake up
looking for a blanket dude you got like
a dish towel an old shoe
[Laughter]
have you ever blown up the bag from a
box of wine and use that as a pillow
that's pretty good though what are you
his childhood friend what the [ __ ] is
happening when you were riding the rails
that is crazy yeah i [ __ ] partied
dude and when you leave your knapsack in
the other car yeah
that's a clutch move after a house party
[ __ ] you ever stand around a fire and
cook a can of beans
[Laughter]
you ever had a hobo do you ever have the
rail guard chase you out of the field
that's [ __ ] that's next level crazy
blew up a bag of wine is a pillow yeah
and not only is this not a me move it's
like a ubiquitous party move dude
everybody knows easy with the big words
there buddy yeah i'm gonna take it as a
fence yo glass is that thick you'd think
you'd know them
[Laughter]
should've seen that one coming though
[Applause]
oh my god can you repeat it i don't
speak hobo
[Laughter]
you know what
you're not getting that bike
and i can't do it for that original
price
gang cousin ian ladies and gentlemen
this will be coming out this week so
plug you plug your dates what do you got
what are you going to be uh this week as
in this is coming out it'll be out
thursday
i love it
april 1st and 2nd vermont comedy club
come on out burlington vermont headline
the weekend i'm bringing jordan jensen
with me it's going to be a blast vermont
go see ian he's yeah
he's the best we love him thank you
animal69 twitter twitch and instagram
sopranosprimavalta and bye guys and
don't feed them because they'll never
leave
that's right
what do we got uh guys callie we're
gonna be in cali this week la is sold
out but there's tickets uh for the la
jolla comedy store as well as cobbs
comedy and sand for sorry sf i want to
be cool then pittsburgh detroit denver
buffalo do it we'll be back in chicago
chicago rosemont chicago there's only a
couple tickets left for the old town
show so [ __ ] get there
is great rosemont as well uh phoenix
salt lake city phoenix and denver
i can't wait to get more dates get your
[ __ ] tickets come out to a live show
also we've been forgetting to plug it's
been available there's merch available
ah
all the t-shirts we've ever had are
available.com backslash are you garbage
something along those lines it'll be in
the description you can go get them
people have been clamoring for all the
classics yes we love you we'll see you
next week
peace